[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Jessica is an
award winning journalist
and critic who writes on
gender, sexuality, and culture
for "The New York Times."
She's covered sexual
assault on campus,
spent time with Hillary
Clinton's childhood friends,
and was the first
journalist to profile
Monica Lewinsky in a decade.
She also writes a regular
column on digital language.
Jessica's first book,
"Feminist Fight Club--
A Survival Manual for
a Sexist Workplace,"
has been hailed as the
millennial "Lean In"
by "The New York Times" and a
must read by "The Guardian."
And yes, she's in a
real life fight club.
[LAUGHTER]
We're going to get started
with a quick video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I'm glad you brought
up millennials.
Our total marketing
reach with millennials
has gone up about 60%.
[OFFICE BACKGROUND NOISES]
Our overall website visits
have also been up about 17%.
And the way that we can
actually change things--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Did you get my
email from Thursday?
Did you guys read that email?
I think that our
primary objective here--
[HEART BEATING]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Fight!
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC PLAYING]
- Our total marketing
reach grew by 15%.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- What I'm looking for is--
- Investing in
strategy, in using our--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- --which is--
- Energy!
- --brought our total marketing
reach up by 16% last year.
- Good point, Amanda.
- Thank you!
- Do you know that
our goals for Q4
are about the roadmap
and the diversity
and the progress of our company?
Our company, if
it's about anything,
we really represent
hashtag progress.
It's really where we
draw our core values.
Brittany, do you mind
taking notes on this
so we get everything down?
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC PLAYING]
- Oh, you know who's really
great at taking notes is Josh.
- Wait, what?
- Fatality.
- Hey, PJ, we need to talk about
the quarterly sales report.
Your team is down about
60% from last quarter.
- Yeah, just give me
like one second, OK.
- Guys, please, guys.
[LAUGHING]
- He got nailed
right in the balls.
- That was hilarious.
- PJ, this is a huge deal.
I have to take this to the CEO.
I need to understand
like what happened.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You need to chillax
a little bit.
You're freaking us out.
You're acting kind of insane.
I think it's that
time of the month.
It's that time of the month.
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC PLAYING]
- Fight.
- If you're talking about
the time of the month
when I do your performance
review, then you're right.
And you're screwed.
- Hey guys, this is Stephanie.
She's the newest
member of our team.
- Hi.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- How's it going, Stephanie?
- Good, nice to meet you.
- Get a load of this chick.
- Fight.
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC PLAYING]
- What is this woman staring at?
- It's like if Ann
Taylor didn't try.
- What is her problem?
- I'm the female on the team.
- Yuck.
- Is she replacing me?
- You should be
threatened by me.
- I love her suit, just kidding.
- Watch out, eyebrows.
- Hi.
I'm Stephanie.
- Nice to meet you.
- It can kind of be a
sausage fest in here.
So I'm really happy to have
another woman in the room.
- Thanks!
- Flawless victory.
You win.
- [SCREAMS] Yes, yes, yes!
Feminism!
Be!
[OPENS CAN]
That was fucking hard.
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER: Can you
give us a back story
on what led you to write
"Feminist Fight Club"
and also how you came up with
all the amazing nomenclature
in the book?
JESSICA BENNETT: I really
like puns as you will see.
So as Melissa mentioned in my
very long, maybe too long bio,
I am in a real life
feminist fight club.
And a number of the
women are in the video.
But it's essentially
a group of creatives.
We are journalists and
writers and comics.
And we began meeting
about a decade ago
when we were just
starting our careers.
We're all in New York City.
And most of us were in very
white male-dominated fields.
And we were struggling.
We were frustrated.
And we didn't know what we could
be doing better to get ahead.
We often questioned whether
what we were experiencing
was actually sexism or something
more individual or personal.
And so we would gather
about once a month
in one of our member's parents'
houses, because we couldn't
put that many people in any
of our tiny studio apartments.
And we would just
talk about what
was going on for
us at work and try
to provide support and offer
each other advice on how
we might try to combat
some of the issues.
So the feminist
fight club was real.
And back then, the first
rule of the fight club was
like in real fight club--
that you didn't
talk about the club.
And that was funny, but
also for real reasons, which
were that a lot of the
women in the group,
who were working
at media outlets
and different
organizations, did fear
that if word got out that they
were in what was essentially
a feminist consciousness
raising group,
they would be either stigmatized
or potentially penalized.
And so we didn't
talk about the club.
But lo and behold, here I am.
So the rules have changed.
And now the first
rule of the fight club
is you must talk
about the fight club.
SPEAKER: Love it.
So at the beginning
of the book, you
kind of admit that the tone
of the book is really light.
And you know, it's very
friendly and casual.
There are a lot of swear words.
So I'm just wondering--
and that's not
to say that it's lacking
in data or substance
or seriousness of subject.
So why did you decide
to write in this tone?
JESSICA BENNETT: Yeah,
I mean on the one hand,
it sort of is my tone.
I can't speak without
swearing apparently.
And as a journalist, I've sort
of come up on the internet.
So I wanted to speak
to young people
in their language, which
is also my language.
And I felt like I've been
working on and writing
about these issues
for a number of years.
But I often was focused on the
problem, not on the solution.
And throughout my work with
Lean In and other outlets,
I always end up reading all
of these academic studies--
that buried somewhere in page 19
there's some little fight move
or solution for how to
combat a 'manterrupter' or a
'mansplainer.'
But it's not used
in that language.
And so I kept
thinking to myself,
if there was some way to just
pull this stuff out and put it
into a format that was fun
to read and digestible,
but also really practical
and rooted in research,
then it would provide a
service that, frankly, I
wish I had when I was
starting my career.
And so I hope that
there's something
in this book for
everyone but I wanted
to speak in a language
that was light.
And you know, sexism
is not a fun topic,
but it can be fun to read about.
SPEAKER: So speaking
about those tactics,
those are more of those
individual or personal tactics
versus policy or
institutional changes.
Why did you decide to focus on
those individual level tactics?
JESSICA BENNETT:
Yeah, I mean I think
that ultimately dealing
with gender equity
needs to come from every level.
So it needs to happen
on a policy standpoint,
though currently in our
leadership in this country,
I'm not very optimistic
that that's going to happen.
It needs to come from a business
and a company standpoint.
But I also think
that I have felt,
in my career for many years,
that I was frustrated.
And I didn't want to wait
around for HR policies
or legal policies or politics
to solve these problems for me.
Not to mention that a lot of the
forms of sexism we face today
can't actually be prosecuted
in court or legalized for.
So what do you do?
Well, there are
actually ways that we
can fight back against
some of this stuff
in our everyday lives.
And it doesn't have
to feel overwhelming.
Some of these are small things.
But we can do it on
behalf of ourselves.
And we can do it on behalf
of our fellow women.
And so I wanted
something that felt
like I had agency, that would
allow me to engage and try
to work towards a larger, more
equal world and more equal work
place that I could do every day.
And so I certainly recognize
the need for policy change
and change from a
corporate level,
but if you feel overwhelmed
in your daily environment,
and you're constantly being
interrupted when you speak,
there are things you
can do to solve that.
SPEAKER: So I want to
talk a little bit more
about those forms
of sexism that you
talk about a lot in the book.
You call it death by
1,000 cuts type of sexism.
It's the insidious, casual,
politically correct,
even friendly sexism or
racism that people experience.
And that is in contrast
with an overt, clear cut
discrimination, like you said,
that has a legal definition.
So why is this kind of
subtle sexism so much harder
to report, so much harder
to fix, and so much easier
to dismiss?
JESSICA BENNETT: I think because
often we've internalized it
in a lot of ways.
I know this is Silicon Valley.
We talk about unconscious
bias a lot here.
I probably don't
need to define that
for the people in this room.
But once upon a time,
sexism was very overt.
And so I began my career at
"Newsweek" as a young writer.
And while I was there,
I started facing things
like pitching an idea and
having it be turned down.
And then seeing it appear
on the pages of the magazine
under a man's byline
a few weeks later.
Or feeling uncomfortable
speaking up
in very white
male-dominated meetings.
Or feeling like if I
negotiated for more money
after finding out that
a man with the same job
title and description was
making thousands of dollars
more than me that I would be
perceived as pushy for wanting
too much.
So it's these subtle things,
whereas the generation prior--
while I was at
Newsweek, I found out
about the women who
had actually sued
that company for
gender discrimination
in the year 1970.
There's an Amazon series
now about these women
called "The Good Girls Revolt."
But at the time, this was
the first case of its kind.
And women who
worked at "Newsweek"
were told yes,
you will be hired.
You can do all of the job
duties that a man can,
but you're not allowed to write.
We don't allow women
to have bylines.
And so at the end
of the day, they
would hand over their notes
and probably a cup of coffee
as well, to a man who
would get the credit.
And they sued.
And they were able to
sue because it was clear
that this was discrimination.
They were saying outwardly
that women are not allowed
to write here and men are.
And so this prompted lawsuits
at "The New York Times"
and "Time" magazine and
"Sports Illustrated."
These women paved the way
for female journalists.
And yet 40 years later,
here I was, I was a writer.
I had the title to prove it.
And yet I was still facing
some of these subtle things
on a daily basis that frankly,
like HR policies can't really
solve for.
Like if you're the default
note taker in a meeting,
or you're constantly
being interrupted,
or you're perceived
as bitchy or bossy
when you make a
command, when that
is what is expected
ultimately of leaders,
what's HR going to do about it?
Some of this stuff
is internalized.
And for what it's worth, it's
not just internalized sexism
that men possess,
it's women as well.
SPEAKER: You include a
ton of data in the book
to back up the type of
sexism and discrimination
that you talk about.
So what sort of practical
advice would you
give to someone who wants to
start sharing this type of data
with their teams to
educate and empower them
with what we have
after reading the book,
without coming off in that way?
JESSICA BENNETT: Yeah, totally,
which we'll just point out
it sucks that we
have to worry about,
and we shouldn't have to.
So lucky for you
there is a book,
it's for sale in the back,
and you can just leave it
underneath bosses' doors.
Put one in the ladies room.
Put one in the men's
room, whatever.
You can tear pages out
of it, do your thing,
and then you can blame it on me.
So it doesn't have
to be-- but actually
there is research showing
that if you can present
an idea on behalf of the
group, rather than on behalf
of yourself, it's more likely
to be accepted or taken
in a way that doesn't leave
you feeling like you're
being too demanding.
So I literally tell people to
print out studies, and bring
them up in whatever
the scenario is.
So OK, women are actually
more likely to be
interrupted than men.
Twice as likely, and more so
if they are a woman of color.
Obviously, in workplaces
where meetings
are such a huge
part of it and ideas
are such a huge part of it,
if you're being interrupted
every time you speak.
You're not contributing ideas,
and you're not ultimately
getting credit.
So OK, how do you stop that?
Well, you can tell
someone to shut up
when they interrupt you.
I can tell someone that I want
to hear what you have to say,
when you're being interrupted,
so that it doesn't
make you look like the bad guy.
Bad guy-- I guess guy's a
gender term-- the bad person.
[LAUGHTER]
But also if you wanted
to casually bring up
that women, in fact, data
shows are twice as likely to be
interrupted as men, there's
a study you can print out,
and there's a footnote in the
back of the book to do that.
And then it's putting
it on data and research,
not on you being too emotional
or touchy and offended
by a certain behavior.
So I say whenever you can
blame something on the data,
it's actually really effective.
And part of the
reason why the book
is so reliant on it,
in addition to me
not liking to just
give personal advice,
because I'm a journalist.
I am trained to not do that.
But it means that you
can always refer back
to a "Harvard Business
Review" study that
can't be argued with.
These are all things we
should do because they're
the right thing to do.
But it can be hard to
tell people that this
is the right thing to do.
So you can tell them that
they should do it because it's
actually better for business.
And companies with more gender
equality have higher returns.
They're more profitable,
more collaborative,
and so there's all of these
really data driven reasons
why it makes sense.
SPEAKER: So in one of
your previous comments
you mentioned unconscious bias.
And unconscious bias
training has seemingly
taken over Silicon Valley.
Can you share some of your
thoughts on implicit bias
and what it means to A,
become aware of it and B,
go through a training
program to address it?
JESSICA BENNETT: Yeah, and
so, for what it's worth,
I did the--
I think it was MIT--
has an implicit bias test,
where you can take it and see
if you're biased.
And yes, I, too, am biased.
So I think it's very
important to talk about this,
and the fact that
implicit bias is
a word that's being
tossed around now
and people know what it means.
It allows us to recognize
that we all have it.
And I think that recognizing
that we all have it
is the first step
toward overcoming it.
I think that some of
the problems with some
of these training programs is
that they don't necessarily
offer solutions.
And so I think while the first
step and a very important step
is recognizing that
we have bias and being
able to notice it or check
for it in the moment,
we have to also think about
changing our behavior.
And so in the moment when
you notice it, what can you
do to stop yourself?
Or how can you point
out when someone else
is exhibiting bias?
And for what it's worth, I
was in a meeting recently.
And a man and a woman walked in.
And I caught myself
in a moment of bias,
assuming that the woman was
the assistant to the man.
And in fact, she was his boss.
And this is like--
I wrote a whole book about this.
I talk about these
issues all the time.
But our brain takes
these cognitive shortcuts
that we have
internalized over, I
mean, literally
thousands and thousands
of years of us
being taught that it
is white men in charge and
women who are supporting that.
And so I feel if I have
it, we all have it.
And so I think it's really
important to talk about it.
And I think that there's no
downside to these training
programs, but I also
think that, especially
here in Silicon Valley, the
idea of diversity and inclusion
and bias trainings,
these are words
that are tossed around a lot.
And we can't just
talk about them.
We need to also have
action associated.
SPEAKER: Absolutely yeah,
because only talking about them
and learning about them
tends to normalize them.
And then nothing gets done
as a result. So on the cover,
there's an asterisk
note for men.
So what is your message for men?
JESSICA BENNETT:
So for those that
don't have the cover
in front of them,
there's a little
asterisk right here.
And then it says book is
21% more expensive for men.
It's not really, because
that would be illegal.
And actually it
should now be 20%,
because we gained a penny,
yay, in the wage gap.
No, my message for men is
ultimately that we need you,
and we cannot fight for equality
without men by our side.
They are so important
to this battle.
And yet I try to use humor as a
way into some of these issues.
And so the 21% is supposed
to be a joke, ha ha.
And in fact, I've seen it
be effective in the sense
that I've seen men
perusing the book.
And then seeing that asterisk
and sort of chuckling and then
opening it up.
So hopefully that's a way in.
And I try to use
humor as a way to talk
about really tricky issues.
You know this stuff is hard.
And sometimes it's
really uncomfortable.
And I think that sometimes
men understandably
feel uncomfortable
engaging on these topics
or knowing how to be an ally.
And so I think it's so
important to include them
in the conversation.
And let them know-- and not
just men, but women, too--
that we are actually going
to screw up sometimes.
We're not going to be perfect
talking about this stuff
all the time.
But with a commitment
to be better, then
we can screw up
and correct for it.
And at the end of the day,
men are half the population.
We cannot achieve equality
without their support.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
So speaking on the
topic of inclusion,
I want to talk a little
bit about intersectionality
and just sort of get your
view on intersectionality
and how it maybe has changed
or evolved, especially
in our current climate.
JESSICA BENNETT: Yes, so
intersectionality for those
who don't know--
the concept that feminism
must be intersectional.
It must also look at the cross
section, the intersection
of race, of class, of gender
identity, of sexuality.
And that really,
feminism is not feminism
if it's not intersectional.
And that's certainly my belief.
This stuff needs
to be incorporated.
And we need to be thinking
about it all the time.
I think that traditionally, the
mainstream women's movement,
at least the public part
that you learn about
in history books or you
read about in the press,
has not done a great job
of taking intersectionality
into account.
Primarily the 1970s movement of
women's liberation was white.
And there were all sorts of
really amazing subgroups, women
of color that were
also rising up.
But they just weren't
talked about as much.
So I do think that right
now what we're seeing
is a much more intersectional
view of all of this.
This is something that we're
talking about regularly.
Mainstream
publications that don't
assume any knowledge
of feminism are using
that word, intersectionality.
"The New York
Times" recently did
it, which was a great
thing for them, I think.
And it's also
important that some
of the new, emerging
leaders we're
seeing talking about this,
the women of the Women's March
are of every race.
And so I think that
it's so important,
because I think
that ultimately you
can't be a feminist if you don't
also care about these issues.
Feminism is intersectional.
SPEAKER: So I want to talk
about one of the pitfalls
that you mentioned in the
book that really affects me.
So I can say I am
an 'ever faithful.'
And that means that
I want to believe
that everything is fair,
that career and the workplace
is a meritocracy.
So what advice would you
give for people like me
who still want to
believe in a meritocracy
and behave as if we exist in
one, despite all the research
that disproves that?
JESSICA BENNETT: I would
say that loyalty does not
pay the bills.
And I think that, as women, we
too often put our heads down
and do good work and expect
to be recognized for it.
And that's not our
fault. Typically, it
is harder for women to
self-promote and call attention
to the good work
that they're doing.
Because when we do, we're
perceived as too braggy
or we're disliked for it.
And so we sort of
internalize these structures
that have told us over
years and years and years
that we're supposed
to be modest.
And so yes, I would
like to believe
it's a meritocracy,
too, but I think
that I'm too cynical for that.
So any moment you can
take to call attention
to your accomplishments
is not a bad thing.
And if you feel uncomfortable
doing it, enlist someone else.
There's a term I have in the
book called 'boast bitch.'
This is a person who
brags on your behalf.
And there's a real
reason for this.
It's because women
are disliked when
they brag about themselves.
But of course, we're working
in competitive office
environments.
We need to draw attention
to the work that we do.
So you and I are both bitches,
we have an unspoken or spoken
agreement.
I boast for you.
You boast for me.
Every time you do
something great,
I send an email to our
entire team and cc you on it.
And then you can look
completely humble.
I'm going to look like
a great colleague.
And everyone gets credit.
So meritocracy, yes, it would
be great if that existed,
but I think that the
numbers show us otherwise.
SPEAKER: I think we need to
create a marketplace at Google
for boast bitches.
You can sign up to be one.
JESSICA BENNETT: If
you feel comfortable
with the word bitch, you can
call it a boast bae, whatever.
And for what it's worth, bitch
in the sense that I mean it,
boast bitch can be
a man or a woman.
Anyone can be a boast bitch.
It's just someone
who has your back.
SPEAKER: Another of
the chapters that I
thought was really powerful
was the one on negotiation.
And I especially loved
the piece of advice
to view your ask in shades
of gray, not black and white.
Can you share your point
of view on negotiation
and how women and men approach
negotiation differently
and therefore get
different results?
JESSICA BENNETT: There's a lot
of research around the issue
of negotiation.
And what the newer
research is finding
is that women who do
negotiate are often
viewed as aggressive
or pushy, and it
makes them less likely to
actually get the raise.
So all right, well, how are
you supposed to overcome that?
There's no real solution to
that other than keep asking,
and it will become normalized.
And then we won't
view a woman who
asks as pushy or aggressive.
But in addition to that, women
are often less likely to ask.
And so I know that when
I was starting my career
I never asked.
I felt so incredibly
lucky to have a job.
This was when I was at
"Newsweek" in the early 2000s,
and journalism was
imploding everywhere.
So I was, in a way,
lucky to be employed.
But it caused me to not ask.
And it wasn't until I realized
there was this other guy who
I worked with, with
the same title,
was making many thousands
of dollars more than me
that I was like, OK, I
have to go in and ask.
And so what I did is I tried to
be very data driven about it.
I didn't want to go in and tell
them that I felt I deserved it
or that I needed to pay
off my student loans.
I wanted to come in with a list
of statistics about the work
that I'd done.
So I added up every possible,
conceivable statistic
you could find in a
field like journalism
where there's not
really metrics.
But so things like page views
on articles, number of articles
written, perceived
value of press
hits that I'd done
on television.
What else?
Anything else I could find.
And I, in fact, then wrote it
up like a Buzzfeed listicle, top
10 list, why you should give
Jessica Bennett a raise.
And I went in and I
tried to express this,
and naturally I was
stuttering and stumbling
over my words in bright red.
But then I followed
up with the email.
So I think it's
important to be really
data focused and data driven.
I think it's important to
know that women do struggle
with this, and they're often
penalized, more so than men.
But truly the way that we're
going to make this equal
is by continuing to ask.
And I think that what
companies can do as well
is look at salary parity.
I think Google is doing
something around this.
But comparing is there
a gap in your company
between men and women, and
if there is, solving for it.
SPEAKER: Yeah, definitely.
That's great advice.
Thank you.
So your feminist fight club
is largely outside of work,
but obviously made up
of professional women.
But inside of the
workplace, would you
recommend a feminist fight
club made up of colleagues?
JESSICA BENNETT: Yeah.
SPEAKER: What do you think
are some of the strengths
and some of the limitations of
that sort of environment taking
place at work?
JESSICA BENNETT:
Yeah, I mean, anyone
can form a feminist fight club.
And there's a guide at the back
of the book on how to do so,
which basically is like
do whatever you want.
And many people, in fact, have
forms of feminist fight clubs.
We called ours that, and we
also had a top secret name
that I can't reveal.
But we thought it was
important for our group
to have a mix of women
in creative industries,
but not all in the same field.
Because we wanted to have
a diversity of voices.
And so we sort of handpicked
based on that, but a lot of it
was also random.
I ended up there
through a mentor
whose daughter was in it.
And a lot of it just
came organically.
But I think that talking
about these issues at work
can be so important.
Lean In circles are now in
companies all over the world.
And I think it's been
really effective to talk
about them with colleagues.
And so forming a
feminist fight club,
yeah, basically
by being here, you
are all members of the
feminist fight club.
Welcome, lifelong
membership, there's
no dues, like you're in.
But you can also
form smaller groups.
And I don't know, for me, having
a group of women who I knew
were unconditionally
supportive, and I could always
turn to if I had a
problem has truly
helped me grow in many ways
throughout my career and even
my personal life.
And I think there's
no downside to it.
I think that we need
to help each other.
The third rule of the
new feminist fight club
is we fight patriarchy,
not each other.
So the idea of
treating other women
as allies, not as enemies.
We don't need to be competitive.
We are more powerful together.
We can lift one another up.
SPEAKER: One of the pieces,
or one of the chapters
that contained a
ton of great advice
was "What Would Josh Do?"
And this was sort
of advice to think
like Josh, who's a male
colleague with chutzpah,
meaning shameless
audacity-- not to be
confused with utter bullshit.
So I'm just wondering,
first of all,
how do you distinguish
between those two?
JESSICA BENNETT: Very hard.
SPEAKER: Because I think I
struggled with that chapter,
because some of the
advice felt like would I
be going against what is
sort of natural to me?
And how much do I
need to work on that?
JESSICA BENNETT:
So yes, the chapter
is called WWJD, the other
J, what would Josh do?
Carry yourself
with the confidence
of a mediocre white man.
And Josh, in fact,
is a real person.
He's not named Josh.
And he's a lovely individual
and a good friend of mine.
But we used to share
a wall at "Newsweek."
We sat next to each other.
And so I got to sort of
observe him in all scenarios.
And we had similar jobs, except
that every time there was
a meeting I would be in my
office with a door closed--
this was back when
people had offices,
I'll never have an office again,
now I just work in my bed--
but I would be studying up for
a pitch meeting, determined
to have every fact right, so
nervous, being so prepared.
And he would be in his
office with his feet
up on the desk, just ready
to go in and bullshit
his way through.
And in his case, he
was also very smart.
So his bullshit was
educated bullshit.
But what the research
shows is that actually we
mistake sometimes
confidence for competence.
And so the way that
he was delivering it,
with such confidence,
was almost as effective
as my really studied, but
unconfident, pitches as well.
And so it allowed
me to observe him.
And so throughout
the chapter, I advise
asking yourself in
various scenarios
WWJD, or WWMD, what
would a man do.
Not so women can start
mimicking male behavior,
but because we often
underestimate ourselves.
And so I know that for
me, in a scenario where
I was feeling nervous or wasn't
sure how to go about something,
I would ask myself
what would Josh do.
And then I would end up
somewhere in the middle.
Like Josh would do this,
I would naturally do this,
I would end up here.
And so often we underestimate
ourselves or we face imposter
syndrome, or we don't
feel like we deserve
to be there or belong, and
so a little bragging actually
may get us to the point
where we should be,
where we're not
underestimating our abilities
and our accomplishments.
So yeah, I probably carry
myself with the confidence
of a mediocre white man.
SPEAKER: I love it.
So last question, you sort of
described yourself as a cynic.
But I'm holding out hope
that you're still hopeful.
And so I'm wondering,
how do you remain
hopeful and humorous and
encouraged when digging
into this research
that's really sort
of challenging to confront?
JESSICA BENNETT: Right, and
what's happening in the world?
Yes, so I try to have a
sense of humor about it.
If I couldn't laugh
about some of this stuff,
I think I would
just be depressed.
So I still try to find humor
in some of these things.
Feminists, in fact,
are really funny.
We do have senses of humor.
There's the joke,
how many feminists
does it take to screw
in a light bulb?
And then it's like,
that's not funny.
But actually it is funny.
We can laugh about this stuff.
It's serious, yes, it's serious.
But we can laugh.
And I also find a lot of hope
in the younger generation.
A lot of the women that
I work with and talk
to for stories and who helped
me on "Feminist Fight Club"
social media are college
women and college men.
And the way that they talk about
and think about these issues
is so much further along
than I was at their age.
The way that they
think about, they
approach this intersectionally.
And the hope that they have?
There is a study that
came out recently
about how Gen Z and
younger millennials
are actually much more
hopeful than the rest of us.
So look to the youth.
The kids are all right.
And so I go to them whenever I
need a dose of bringing me up.
SPEAKER: I love that.
Thank you.
So now I want to open it up to
questions from the audience.
And Lizzie has a microphone.
AUDIENCE: So we were just
talking about this before.
Every now and then,
something happens
where a man does something
that's well-intentioned,
but tone deaf.
So recently we got an
email from some men
inviting us to a
mixer for women.
I thought, why are the
men inviting us to this?
Why is there not a woman
throwing the mixer,
and why are the men
even part of it?
And so I asked my boss, like
this is pretty tone deaf.
And his response was yes,
but it was well-intentioned.
How do you respond to that?
Because I feel like a
message could, maybe should,
get to the men who sent it,
but it was well-intentioned.
And so why do we
want to bring it up?
JESSICA BENNETT: I mean
I would say that you
have to call these things out.
Like you don't have to be a
bitch calling this stuff out,
or be perceived as a bitch.
It's important to talk about it.
And so if it is tone deaf,
then he should let them know.
So I don't know.
So much of this stuff
is so individual.
Depends on your power
within the organization.
Is this person your boss?
Do you feel comfortable
speaking up?
And I always fall back
on, if it's not just you,
if it's a number of women
part of that group who
are asking for
something to happen,
then not any individual
can be singled out.
And so perhaps the response
would be for multiple of you
to go back and say,
I totally understand.
And I appreciate you passing
this information along
or whatever it may be.
Because a lot of this
is tone deafness.
And we make mistakes.
But no one is going
to learn if they don't
know that they're tone deaf.
And so the message needs to
make it back to those people.
AUDIENCE: I think my question
is around the incidents that
have sort of played out at
Uber, which have become pretty
well-known, I think, especially
here in Silicon Valley
over the last few weeks.
And I think obviously
that was an extreme case,
that the writer sort of talked
about in her article on Medium.
But I think for a
lot of us that work
in Silicon Valley as women,
we're like, of course.
These subtle daily acts of
sexism happen every day.
Why is this so
surprising to people?
But I think one
thing that made me
start thinking was one
of the follow up articles
was talking about how Uber's
performance system is a bell
curve.
And how they have five
performance buckets.
And it sort of encourages people
to undercut their teammates,
or because of things
like imposter syndrome,
it encourages the men to shine
and the women not to shine.
And then I think that their
performance system is probably
directly modeled after Google's,
or it's very, very similar
from what it sounds like.
So my question to you is, have
you read anything about that
or have you thought about
that or do you have any sort
of data-- and, I haven't read
it yet but I'm excited to--
but data that sort of supports
this idea of performance
and the best ways to
measure that so it's not
a systemic problem for men
versus women succeeding
in a company?
JESSICA BENNETT: Right.
Well, I think that one
very important thing
is setting really clear
criteria for success.
So Lean In and McKinsey put out
this study every year of women
in the workplace.
And this past one, they
found that something
like 78% of companies said that
they support gender equality.
or it was the employees
saying that they
believe their CEOs really
supported gender equality.
And yet like 50% of the
managers in those companies
didn't actually know what to do.
And then only 38%
of those companies
actually set clear criteria
for things like hiring.
And what we know is that, at
least as it pertains to hiring,
but I imagine it pertains
to performance reviews
as well, women are
often judged based
on their past performance,
and men are judged
based on their potential.
So literally we have to have
a line item on our resume
and looking at a man, you're
like, wow, he could do it.
I can see him as
a future leader.
And oftentimes, those
people seeing those people
as future leaders are also men.
And so the reality is
it's sometimes easier
to see someone who
looks like you rise up.
So what can you do?
Well, if you have
very clear criteria
and you know that
that's existing,
then you can set metrics for it.
And you can make
sure that you're not
hiring or reviewing
based on what you think
a person's potential may be.
I don't know specifically what
companies have done to try to,
I don't know, I guess
solve for that bell curve.
But I have to think that
having more women in leadership
to talk about these things--
I mean it's like
the same reason why
we were talking about earlier.
Our microphones don't clip
on to the back of a dress.
Because they were made by men,
and they were made for men.
And so you see this across
the board in small things
and large things.
And if women are involved
in the decisionmaking
process about how
people are judged
or about how whatever
this may be in this case,
then I think that they can
elevate some of these issues.
So that's not a perfect
solution on how to do it,
but I think all of this
stuff is so interconnected.
And until half of the
leaders are women,
we will continue to
have these problems.
But I also think it's important
that people are speaking
out and talking about it.
That woman writing that piece
that went completely viral
has sparked a conversation that,
yes, I totally agree many of us
are like, yeah, duh.
Obviously this is happening.
We know this.
But it appears that a lot
of people didn't know it.
And it's getting mainstream
press attention now,
which is a good thing.
And Uber is obviously
under scrutiny
to change some of its policies.
And so I think that,
or I hope that, we'll
see a ripple effect there.
But oftentimes it
does take someone
speaking out and going out
on a limb, which is why
I go back to power in numbers.
She wasn't working at
the company anymore,
so she felt comfortable
speaking out.
But for those who
are inside, sometimes
it helps to band together
and approach it as a group.
Because you can't be penalized.
You're more powerful.
And if you're
experiencing something,
probably someone else is, too.
AUDIENCE: Any resources to share
about language to push back
on disempowering praise?
I recently got 'she's
a smart cookie'
on a project I'm leading.
I have a PhD in
neuroscience, and eight years
of industry experience.
I'm not a cookie.
I am an expert.
Any advice?
JESSICA BENNETT: Call it out.
Yeah, you're not.
I call that the underminer.
The person who's
like, great job,
kiddo, or thank you,
honey, or cookie.
All of those little language
pieces that are so tiny,
but they're so undermining.
If you're standing
there and your team
sees you being called a
cookie by some other leader,
are they going to respect you?
So I think calling
it out sometimes
you may have to take that person
aside and be like, hey, we're
all in this for the same thing.
I think it actually
benefits you for our team
to see me as a leader.
And when you call me a cookie,
it undermines my authority,
so calling out the behavior.
You know I think that
we're being more cognizant
these days of speech patterns.
So from things like
that to the way
that so much of our
language is gendered.
I've started trying
to find alternative
when I say you guys.
But
Even things like--
there's a dictionary
in the book, an A
to Z-- it's "How
Not to Be a Dick-tionary,
an A to Z Guide to Nonsexist
Language."
But things that I
had never realized,
like the word seminal.
It comes from semen.
That is a male-derived term.
And that is what we use
to describe great works.
And so this stuff
is so, so ingrained
into every tiny
bit of our culture.
And sometimes it's a matter of
calling it out when we see it,
because people do
not even realize it.
And for what it's worth,
would you call a man cookie?
No.
You can pretty much apply
that question to anything.
Would I view her as
bossy if she were a man?
Probably not, so asking
that question as well.
AUDIENCE: Trying to
formulate this question--
I guess this is about
any lessons learned
from male allies.
And I guess I'm seeing this
through the lens of anxiety.
You know, anxiety is
important, because it
pushes people to change.
But it can also
prompt a backlash.
And I like the language
that you used about, hey,
I'm actually trying
to be helpful to us.
So just any thoughts
that you have again,
like things that
you feel have been
successful in sort of
recruiting allies or getting
mind shift in allies
to see common cause,
anything like that.
JESSICA BENNETT: Yeah, I mean,
I think just talking more
openly is really step one.
Because I think we're hesitant
to talk about these issues.
And we're fearful that
we're going to screw up.
And you know, I
wrote a whole book
that has language like
mansplaining and manterruption
and bro-appropriation
everywhere.
And on some level, that
can make men feel targeted.
I'm also trying
to use it as a way
to have humor to open
up some of these issues.
But I think we have
to get over our fears
about talking about it.
And just discuss more openly
so that the stigma goes away.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just sort
of a follow up thought
to that is basically
I have this notion
of sort of lowering the
cost for screwing up.
I mean I guess it's
proportional to the screw
up, like in some ways we'd
have to raise the cost.
But for those like
maybe microaggressions
should have a micro price.
And it's basically
look, you know,
I appreciate that we're
all working together.
And making it less like--
I read an article that
was like basically,
implicit bias is the new way
to say that you're a racist.
And the person was just
like, I'm not a racist.
It's like, no, oh, my god.
It is the exact
opposite, it's trying
to say we all, because
of us as primates,
we have these
cognitive shortcuts.
It's meant to say look,
you're in good company.
But it's having kind
of the opposite effect.
JESSICA BENNETT:
That's interesting.
I mean I try to
talk about the ways
that I've screwed up frequently
as a way to let my audience
or whomever it may be know
that if I'm doing it too,
then we're all doing it.
And it's OK.
And so maybe one
way to approach it,
at least from trying to get
other people on your side,
is by beginning with
something that you've
done that you realized.
And then maybe they
won't feel attacked.
I mean we shouldn't have
to dance around this issue
and walk on eggshells.
But the reality is that like
we work in office environments,
and we want to be respectful,
and we don't want people
to feel attacked or offended.
And I think that the reality
is that most men really
do want to help, and
they want to be allies.
And I believe
that, but it's also
backed in all sorts of data,
and especially young men.
They want gender equality,
they want equal relationships.
But for hundreds and hundreds
of years, men have run shit.
And so there is
a learning curve.
It does take some time to
overcome some of these issues.
So yeah, I think
talking about a way
that you have experienced
it is one way,
and talking about
things in groups
so that one person
doesn't feel attacked.
But also just knowing that
sometimes uncomfortable stuff
is going to come up.
But we can still have productive
conversations about it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I have
just a couple of questions
that I'll try to keep short.
What do we do about the fact
that the F word of feminism
turns some people
off immediately,
and how do we get those people
back into the conversation
hopefully?
JESSICA BENNETT: Let me do--
I'll do that one first.
So I really do think that the
stigma around the word feminism
is changing.
I think that
celebrities have had
a lot to do with this in fact.
Seeing Beyonce onstage at
the VMAs defining the word--
that's bigger than any other
feminist could ever accomplish.
So I think that the
stigma is going away.
I also think that
continuing to talk
about what the definition
of feminism actually is-- it
means that it's a person
that believes in gender
equality between the sexes.
And that's the most
benign thing ever.
Who's going to say
they're anti-that?
So I think that it's going away.
I also think I'm of the
belief that if you don't
want to call
yourself a feminist,
but you believe in these
things, and you're going
to fight for them, like fine.
That's better than nothing.
And so whether you call
yourself a feminist or not,
I think it's about
working towards equality.
And for what it's worth,
when I was pitching
this book in the beginning,
which was a couple of years
ago, I said to my
male agent, do you
think we should call
this ladies fight club,
because people are going to
be so offended by the word
feminist.
And I'm coming from a
mainstream news background.
I didn't want to go with
a niche feminist press.
I wanted this book
to reach the masses.
And he to his
credit was like, no.
Feminist is a stronger title.
We're going to go out with that.
And so we did.
And I was sort of wary.
I was nervous about
what would happen.
And to my surprise, we
had bids from a dozen
different mainstream publishers,
not niche feminist presses.
And so that to me
was very encouraging.
And I think that that
was still two years ago.
I think that the word has become
more mainstream since then.
But there will
always be arguments
about the word feminism.
For so long, this has occurred.
And I don't know, every
decade or so there's
a conversation around
should we rebrand feminism,
should we call it
something else?
And I don't think
that's going to happen,
but if you're willing to
wear the title proudly,
I say do it loud.
AUDIENCE: And then just
around intersectionality--
I feel like I'm often fearful
that I've heard people
in other minority
groups who are also
women complain that they feel
like their voices are not
heard.
What advice do you
have for white women
or anyone who wants to make
sure that they're supporting
and raising up those voices,
rather than potentially,
accidentally talking over
them or shutting them out
of the conversation?
JESSICA BENNETT: I
think first of all
trying not to be defensive.
Because I see this
happen online so much.
Where white women are called
out for some of their behavior,
and probably much
in the same way
that men feel attacked at
work, the immediate response
is defensiveness.
And I think that we
need to listen more.
We need to listen more.
We need to respect that these
voices have been marginalized
for years and years and years.
So even if we may not think
in a particular moment
that we are drawing
them out, we have long
had a voice, not as much of
a voice as men, but a voice.
And there was a
really long history
of racism in the
women's movement.
And so I think, yeah, we have
to be OK with screwing up.
And be OK with being
called out for it,
and try to correct the
behavior and move on, I think.
AUDIENCE: You sort
of addressed this.
But let's go
directly to it again.
One of the senior
leaders on my team
has recently received
a bit of flack
for using guys too
often as a blanket term
when addressing a
mixed gender group.
It doesn't bother me, yet
when someone uses ladies
to email only admins, it does.
What's your take on
sensitivities like that?
JESSICA BENNETT: I think we need
to just right here, right now,
come up with a
better term for guys.
Like y'all feels
weird to me, folks.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JESSICA BENNETT:
OK, yes, so maybe we
have solved this
right here, thank you.
AUDIENCE: We do have
another unicorn.
JESSICA BENNETT: Yes,
thank you to the unicorn
in the room, one of two.
AUDIENCE: You all?
JESSICA BENNETT: You all, yes.
I mean--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JESSICA BENNETT: Who would
have thought the South would
be so progressive?
Yeah, I think that this stuff is
so entrenched in our language.
AUDIENCE: All of you also.
I need all of you
to focus on this.
JESSICA BENNETT: Yeah.
I mean I need to get more
comfortable with folks.
Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JESSICA BENNETT: Yeah, or
we come up with it more.
AUDIENCE: You humans.
Even human-- hu- man.
Basically all language is sexist
if you really get down to it.
AUDIENCE: About a year ago, I
had an incident with a friend,
a good friend who was
talking about the efforts
going on for hiring
diverse people.
This was a very respectful
person that I am on good terms
with.
But he said, you know that--
to use his words, and
I still remember this--
the pendulum has swung too far.
And people are being
hurt by these efforts,
like basically
good people are not
being hired because like
something, something,
we're looking for
diverse candidates,
implying the woman thing.
And I didn't know how to
respond at the time, which
was going to be like not--
I didn't want to say, blah,
blah, blah, blah, feminism.
JESSICA BENNETT: That's
what I want to do.
AUDIENCE: But like I
wanted to say that,
but it's not going
to solve the problem.
And I don't know
how to address it.
Advice please.
JESSICA BENNETT: Yeah,
and feel free to chime in
if anyone else has advice, too.
Well, as you were saying that
I want to do rah, rah, rah,
feminism thing for the record.
I mean it's tricky.
It's yeah, well,
welcome to history
where these people
have been marginalized
and not hired for years
and years and years.
And we have to correct
for that somehow.
But I think that also--
I don't know, I mean
throwing the numbers back
in that person's face.
Like probably they're
referencing a team or a company
that is still
majority white male,
even if this person feels that
the pendulum has swung too far.
And then potentially making
note of the fact that actually,
it's better for the company
to have a more diverse team.
And listing off all those
stats about how teams
with more diversity
are more collaborative
and more successful.
And companies with more women on
the board have higher returns.
And even things like
in a room in a meeting
where there are at
least 25% women, which
is what social science calls
the point of critical mass,
then those women
in the room will A,
feel more comfortable speaking
up, and B, what they are saying
will actually be heard more.
It's sort of this
point where we stop
viewing that 24%
as a minority group
or as speaking on
behalf of women
or on behalf of
their race, and just
view them as experts
who are in the room.
So that's not a perfect
answer, but trying
to remind that person.
Does anyone else want to
chime in with their thoughts?
AUDIENCE: So moving on
to a different note,
you brought up imposture
syndrome, which
I think a lot of people in
this room can identify with,
myself included.
You know that you're
good at your job.
Logically, you understand that
you do a good job every day,
and an email comes in
on Friday afternoon
with your manager
asking to meet with you.
And you panic, right?
Because you're like, oh,
I'm totally in trouble.
There's no doubt.
JESSICA BENNETT: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm totally
getting fired, right.
JESSICA BENNETT: He should fire
me, in fact, I'll just quit.
AUDIENCE: Right,
exactly, like maybe I'll
just quit on Friday afternoon
so I don't have to have anxiety
all weekend about it.
What are your tips
for dealing with that
and trying to deal with the
internalized sense of I'm
a failure or I'm
going to be a failure
or should be a failure, right?
JESSICA BENNETT: Right.
I think first knowing that
you are not the only one
to feel this way.
Imposture syndrome,
this sense that you
don't belong, that you
don't deserve to be there,
that you're not good at your
job-- this disproportionately
statistically affects
women and minorities,
so LGBT, racial minorities.
And oftentimes it's because
those groups of people
have this added pressure
of accomplishing firsts,
or needing to not fuck
up, because they'll
be judged on behalf of
their gender or their race
if they do.
So first off knowing
that literally I
power posed before I go onstage.
And I was speaking at
a law firm on Monday.
And it was a paid gig.
And I was like literally why
are these people paying me?
Like I should pay them,
like I can't believe--
and it was like a well-paid--
I was like, I don't
deserve this much.
So OK, so we all experience it.
So you're not alone.
Second, you can try
to trick your brain
and this has been
found to be effective,
so that instead of
focusing on how you feel,
you focus on the issue
of imposture syndrome.
Like it's not me, it's the
imposter syndrome talking.
And literally like
saying that in the mirror
has been proven to be effective
in trying to overcome it.
Because it makes it an
issue, not your issue.
I also think that having
friends and allies and members
of your feminist fight club or
whomever it is to remind you
that you're not getting fired.
You don't suck.
It's going to be OK.
I know that you're
good at what you do--
can be the voice that
you need inside your head
to support you.
There's other things you can
do, too, like power posing.
There's a list of
them in the book.
But I think that remembering
that you know, Sheryl Sandberg,
says she felt like a fraud.
And Meryl Streep, the
woman with the most Oscars
has said that every
time she wins an award,
she thinks they must
have made a mistake.
And so it's all of us, and
even some of the world's most
famous and successful people.
SPEAKER: Thank you all so
much for your questions.
And thank you, Jessica.
[APPLAUSE]